programming throwdown episode 100 100th episode take it away patrick well it it is April of 2020 and the whole world is experiencing COVID-19. So we're going to have a celebration of our 100th episode. We're going to try not to dwell too much on it. We have some work from home stuff we might talk about in another episode or two and some tips and tricks we've learned. But this week, we want to use our intro topic to complain about how terrible all video conferencing is. Now that we're all stuck dealing with it all the time. Video conferencing is hard. I get it.
Programming Throwdown 第 100 期。第 100 期了，Patrick，开始吧。嗯，现在是 2020 年 4 月，全世界都在经历 COVID-19。所以我们要庆祝我们的第 100 期节目。我们尽量不去过多纠结这件事。我们有一些关于居家办公的内容，可能会在之后的一两期节目中讨论，还有一些我们学到的小技巧。但本周，我们想用开场话题来吐槽一下所有的视频会议软件有多糟糕。既然我们现在都被困在其中，不得不一直使用它们。视频会议很难，我明白。
But man, it's just brutal, the latency. And for me, I never knew until this, we've talked about to various guests who work remotely and talking about working remotely. And when everyone works remotely, individually, and with the current latency and everything, what I underestimated is how hard it is to read a room. So how much I rely on like, saying something and looking at people and understanding, are they hearing what I'm saying? Is it interesting? Do I need to like, it because they look confused and then just have given up on that? It's like doing the podcast. It's just talking to an empty
但是天哪，那延迟简直太残酷了。对我来说，在此之前我从未意识到这一点，我们和各种远程工作的嘉宾聊过远程工作的话题。当每个人都各自远程工作时，加上目前的延迟等等，我低估了“察言观色”有多难。我有多依赖于在说些什么的时候观察人们，去理解他们是否听懂了我在说什么？这有意思吗？我需要……因为他们看起来很困惑，然后就放弃了？这就像做播客一样。就像对着一个空荡荡的
audience and hoping that at the end they'll ask questions. Yeah, exactly. The latency for me is such a killer. And I feel like it's something that could be solved so easily. I mean, basically, you know, I think the actual true latency, like if I want to send a packet to any one of the people on the call, that that should be much less than a second. So so it's really just that there's buffering and they want it to feel natural and not stutter and everything, which that makes sense. But then at least give us something where we can like like i could press the space bar and my face would just glow so people know that i have something to say and then and then maybe like you know you when someone's talking the person who wants to talk next could just press the space bar and if like two people do it at the same time it would just randomly pick one um but instead what
听众席说话，希望最后他们会提问。是的，完全正确。对我来说，延迟简直是致命的。我觉得这是一个可以轻易解决的问题。我的意思是，基本上，你知道，我认为真正的延迟，比如如果我想给通话中的某个人发送一个数据包，那应该远小于一秒。所以，这其实只是因为有缓冲，他们希望感觉自然，不会卡顿等等，这说得通。但至少给我们提供一种方式，比如我可以按空格键，我的脸就会发光，这样人们就知道我有话要说，然后，你知道，当有人在说话时，想发言的人可以按空格键，如果两个人同时按，它就随机选一个。嗯，但相反，你得到的是
you have is you know somebody talks and then they never really know if someone else has anything to say. So they keep talking. Finally, they stop. And then there's this pause and everyone interrupts each other at the same time. Yeah. Some of that, I feel like cultural and etiquette are going to evolve. I think this might be one of those things we look back on depending on how all this lasts and laugh about how bad it was in the beginning.
你知道，有人在说话，然后他们永远不知道别人是否有话要说。所以他们继续说。最后，他们停下来了。然后是一阵沉默，每个人又同时打断对方。是的。我觉得其中一些文化和礼仪会演变。我想这可能是我们回顾过去时，取决于这一切持续多久，会嘲笑当初它是多么糟糕的事情之一。
And I think maybe we kind of devise some etiquette for how to do stuff so like what is appropriate or inappropriate how do you like like you said like did you raise your hand and someone is like the the shell holder and they pass the shell to the next person uh and you know they're the ones who get to speak um yeah i don't know i think we can make it better but for now now, oh, not good. Yep. Yep. It's just a painful period. But I think actually one thing that really impressed me is the fact that you could have 20, 30, even 40 people in a call. We use this software called BlueJeans where I work.
我想也许我们会制定一些关于如何处理事情的礼仪，比如什么是合适的或不合适的，你该怎么做，就像你说的，你是举手吗？还是有人拿着“发言权”，然后他们把发言权传给下一个人，你知道，他们才是能说话的人。嗯，我不知道，我想我们可以让它变得更好，但目前，哦，不太好。是的，是的。这只是一个痛苦的时期。但我认为实际上有一件事让我印象深刻，那就是你可以在一个通话中容纳 20、30 甚至 40 个人。我工作时使用一种叫 BlueJeans 的软件。
I think it might only be for enterprise. I don't know if anyone can just go on BlueJeans. I'm actually going to look this up now. Yeah, I think it... Oh, no, I think... Well, no, it has a trial. Yeah, so it's basically for enterprise. It costs money. But it's amazing how many people can go in one call.
我想它可能只针对企业。我不知道是否任何人都可以直接使用 BlueJeans。我其实现在就要查一下。是的，我想它……哦，不，我想……嗯，不，它有试用版。是的，所以它基本上是针对企业的。它要收费。但令人惊奇的是，有多少人可以进入同一个通话。
That part really impressed me. So I actually feel like the technology, you know, given the way the media is, the technology is pretty good, probably as good as it could get. But it's just that, you know, the limitations require us to communicate a little differently. And we just haven't figured that out yet. I mean, what's your take? Do you think that the tech itself is bad or just that we haven't figured out how to use it? I think both. So I think the well, that's, I guess, a cop out answer. So I mean, I think the tech, the latency is tough. But I think we've also just not adjusted to the sort of norms for it and doing these big group like running things the same
那部分真的让我印象深刻。所以我实际上觉得技术，你知道，考虑到媒体的情况，技术已经相当不错了，可能已经达到了极限。但只是，你知道，局限性要求我们以不同的方式进行交流。而我们还没有弄明白这一点。我的意思是，你怎么看？你认为技术本身很糟糕，还是我们只是还没弄明白如何使用它？我认为两者都有。所以我认为，嗯，那大概是一个逃避的回答。所以我的意思是，我认为技术，延迟问题很棘手。但我也认为我们只是还没有适应它的规范，像以前一样运行这些大型团体会议。
way they used to run. So we continue to run online meetings like we used to run in-person meetings. And I think maybe that's just not the right way. I don't know what the right way is, but maybe that's not the right way. So even just the UI, so we've had large meetings similarly with our software with 20, 30 people, but then like it won't fit all of the faces
所以我们继续像以前面对面开会那样运行在线会议。我想也许那不是正确的方式。我不知道什么是正确的方式，但也许那不是。所以即使是 UI，我们用我们的软件进行过类似的 20、30 人的大型会议，但它无法同时在屏幕上显示所有人的脸。
on the screen at the same time. Like how do you choose who to display? I don't think the sort of invent, the way we always use it before is like one room connecting to another room or one person dialing into a meeting. We've never had a, you know, 20, 30 person meeting where everyone's in their own room. And so it is actually, as you said, somewhat impressive that it works at all with that many people and getting all of the video streams into one place processing them and sending them out back to everyone i mean that is not an easy problem yeah yeah i think
就像你如何选择显示谁？我不认为这种……我们以前使用它的方式是一个房间连接到另一个房间，或者一个人拨入会议。我们从来没有过 20、30 人的会议，每个人都在自己的房间里。所以，正如你所说，它能容纳这么多人，并将所有视频流汇集到一个地方进行处理，然后再发送回给每个人，这确实令人印象深刻，我的意思是，这不是一个简单的问题。是的，是的，我想
you're right the latency is is is something that i don't think it can really be solved if you're sending video especially at that quality but yeah it just needs to be handled better so that um so that people could communicate without cutting each other off maybe another way of putting it is i feel like the technology is good but the product isn't good maybe that's a that's a better way to say but i would say maybe the product isn't wasn't built with this use case in mind like it's uh it's the most adjacent thing but it wasn't at least how we're using it it's not the most adjacent you're totally right it's not the it using it, it's not the most adjacent. You're totally right. It wasn't designed for that use case. Yep, yep.
你是对的，延迟是我认为如果发送视频，尤其是那种质量的视频，就无法真正解决的问题。但是的，它确实需要处理得更好，这样人们才能在不打断对方的情况下交流。也许换个说法是，我觉得技术很好，但产品不好。也许那是一个更好的说法。但我会说，也许这个产品在构建时并没有考虑到这个用例，它是最接近的东西，但它不是……至少在我们使用它的方式上，它不是最接近的。你是完全正确的，它不是最接近的。你完全正确。它不是为那个用例设计的。是的，是的。
It's almost like someone needs to make a new product. Yeah. And all of those people are working from home using their own product trying to build the fixes. So they also are struggling, right? They're all like, no, our person team, this is not working well. So I'm sure it's a pain point for them. And they're probably trying to fix it, but it'll take time for them to. there's a lot of complexity around the details there, but, but, uh, if someone comes up with a new way for, you know, 10 people to, you know, all talk with each other, uh, without constantly
这几乎就像有人需要制造一个新产品。是的。而所有那些人都在家里使用他们自己的产品，试图构建修复程序。所以他们也在挣扎，对吧？他们都在想，不，我们的团队，这运行得不好。所以我肯定这对他们来说是一个痛点。他们可能正在尝试修复它，但这需要时间。关于那里的细节有很多复杂性，但是，嗯，如果有人想出一种新方法，让 10 个人可以互相交谈，而不会不断地
interrupting each other, I think they could easily disrupt, uh, whoever's at the top right now, I guess maybe zoom is at the top. I don't know. They seem to be the most one in the press. So I know they're constantly in the press and and some of the things are pretty wild i don't know how true they are there's something like all of the um um all of the information is going to like a server offshore or something i don't know there's a lot of weird stories about zoom yeah well i mean it's the classic engineering trope to say that uh i understand one thing i understand all the things so this can't be that hard yeah exactly so you're right maybe an opportunity for someone someone new in the space to come in and uh to take advantage of all this i don't know i guess although the internet pipes
打断对方，我认为他们可以轻易地颠覆现在处于顶端的人，我想也许 Zoom 处于顶端。我不知道。他们似乎是媒体中最常提到的。所以我知道他们经常出现在媒体上，有些事情相当疯狂，我不知道它们有多真实。有传言说所有的信息都发送到了海外的服务器之类的，我不知道，关于 Zoom 有很多奇怪的故事。是的，嗯，我的意思是，这是一个经典的工程比喻，说“我理解一件事，我就理解所有事情，所以这不可能那么难”。是的，完全正确。所以你是对的，也许这对空间里的新人来说是一个机会，可以进来利用这一切。我不知道，我想虽然互联网管道
are might just fall over uh i know for me are they still uh are they still doing standard def for YouTube and all the video streaming, Netflix? Yeah, I think a lot of them are rolling it out. Just they're crumbling under the 300, 400, 500% increase in utilization. I think YouTube, they changed the default down, but you can still bump it back up if you would like to. Got it. you can still bump it back up uh if you you elect to got it so yeah i mean it's just completely unexpected um to have something like uh 300 increase in usage for something like youtube it's unbelievable so for news and our sites of the month sites of the month i like that oh i just made that up right now um so so my first one is I did not know about this before.
可能会崩溃。我知道对我来说，他们还在为 YouTube 和所有视频流媒体、Netflix 做标清吗？是的，我想他们中的许多人正在推出。他们只是在 300%、400%、500% 的利用率增长下崩溃。我想 YouTube，他们调低了默认值，但如果你愿意，你仍然可以调回去。明白了。你可以调回去，如果你选择的话。明白了。所以是的，我的意思是，对于像 YouTube 这样的东西，使用量增加 300% 是完全出乎意料的，这令人难以置信。所以对于新闻和我们的月度网站，月度网站，我喜欢这个。哦，我刚才编出来的。所以，我的第一个是，我之前不知道这个。
And then, you know, people publishing this like, you know, now that you and we should we should give a shout out, you know, if you've if you've been furloughed or lost your job, you know, my heart goes out to you because, yeah, I think that's happening to a lot of people. I'm very fortunate. It hasn't happened to me, you know, but I know that's a lot of people. So complaining about work from home is a little bit of a privileged stance, I guess, because it's good to actually be able to work. So if you haven't been, you know, apologies, shout outs. I know students, students are struggling right now. A lot of part time work as this appeared. So so my heart goes out to you. If you do have free time, though, or, you know, you're just stuck inside because you're under a
然后，你知道，人们发布这个，就像，现在你和我们应该，我们应该表示敬意，你知道，如果你被停薪留职或失去了工作，你知道，我为你感到难过，因为，是的，我想这正在发生在很多人身上。我很幸运。这没有发生在我身上，你知道，但我知道很多人都这样。所以抱怨居家办公有点特权阶层的姿态，我想，因为实际上能够工作是件好事。所以如果你没有，你知道，抱歉，向你们致敬。我知道学生，学生们现在很挣扎。随着这个出现，很多兼职工作都没了。所以，我为你感到难过。不过，如果你有空闲时间，或者，你知道，你只是因为被困在某个地方的居家令下而待在室内，在这个美好的世界里。嗯，这个网站，我之前甚至不知道它的存在。
shelter in place somewhere in this wonderful world. uh this site i didn't know that this even existed before uh now that it did i'm i'm got it open and i'm uh starting to to kind of do this and that's uh learn.unity.com and this is sort of the unity platform which we've i think we had a whole episode about um their website for learning how to program and use Unity. And they've made these teaching sessions free for three months. And they have projects like a first-person shooter or like a go-kart game where you can go in and make modifications, small changes, learn how it works. And I think that's really cool. For me, starting from scratch or even with just a game engine or something like Unity
现在我知道了，我打开了它，我开始尝试做这个，那就是 learn.unity.com，这是 Unity 平台，我想我们有一整期节目是关于它的。他们的网站是关于学习如何编程和使用 Unity 的。他们已经让这些教学课程免费三个月了。他们有像第一人称射击游戏或卡丁车游戏这样的项目，你可以进去进行修改、做些小改动，学习它是如何工作的。我觉得这真的很酷。对我来说，从零开始，或者即使只是用像 Unity 这样的游戏引擎
and building up a whole project is pretty intimidating. But I definitely could go in and change some of the assets for a first-person shooter or the physics or change it into adding up some HUD or something. And they have a number of tutorials here that are free at least for the next three months um i wasn't ever i wasn't able to find out how much it costs normally it didn't look that hard but for the next three months at least this is a cool thing to be able to do so if you've ever had an interest in sort of playing around in game programming i i would take advantage of this i'm planning to get download some of these projects and sort of goof around
构建一个完整的项目是非常令人生畏的。但我绝对可以进去修改一些第一人称射击游戏的资产，或者物理效果，或者把它改成添加一些 HUD 之类的东西。他们这里有很多教程，至少在接下来的三个月里是免费的。我没能查到它通常要多少钱，看起来并不难，但至少在接下来的三个月里，这是一件很酷的事情。所以如果你曾经对玩游戏编程感兴趣，我会利用这个机会。我计划下载其中一些项目，自己瞎折腾一下。
with them myself i think for my kids it would be a good opportunity yeah they're probably not going to use this to learn to program they're still a little bit young but have them tell me what they would like to see and be able to do it for them and be the kind of uh hero in their eyes at least which i guess is a kind of a low bar but you know be able to do something specific i want a pumpkin oh sure here let's let's make a pumpkin and then they can have a game that they they helped build yeah this is awesome i'm taking a look at it now um yeah there's a ton of really good resources here unity is definitely um sort of taking over as as as the game engine now and the thing about game engines it's kind of like it's kind of like, it's kind of like you have those web apps that they make for the phone. And the things don't quite feel right.
我觉得对我的孩子们来说，这将是一个很好的机会。是的，他们可能不会用这个来学习编程，他们还太小，但让他们告诉我他们想看到什么，我能为他们做到，并在他们眼中成为某种英雄，虽然我想这门槛有点低，但你知道，能够做一些具体的事情。“我想要一个南瓜。”“哦，当然，来，让我们做一个南瓜。”然后他们就可以拥有一个他们帮忙构建的游戏。是的，这太棒了，我现在正在看。嗯，是的，这里有大量非常好的资源。Unity 绝对是现在作为游戏引擎接管了一切。关于游戏引擎的事情是，它有点像，它有点像，它有点像你手机上的那些网页应用。它们感觉不太对劲。
So because it's HTML and JavaScript, but they're trying to make it feel like the iPhone UI, the slider doesn't quite move right. There's just not as much inertia on the slider. It's just kind of this uncanny valley. I think that Unity is getting such a market share that everyone else is getting kind of put into that uncanny valley. Where now, if I play a game that isn't on the Unity engine, they're just weird. It just doesn't behave like everything else. And so if you're interested in doing games and they might
因为它是 HTML 和 JavaScript，但他们试图让它感觉像 iPhone 的 UI，滑块移动得不太对。滑块上的惯性不够。这只是一种恐怖谷效应。我认为 Unity 正在获得如此大的市场份额，以至于其他所有东西都被放进了那个恐怖谷。现在，如果我玩一个不是基于 Unity 引擎的游戏，它们就显得很奇怪。它就是不像其他东西那样表现。所以如果你对做游戏感兴趣，它们甚至可能
even get into um other sort of you know visual if you have to do maybe interactive charts or something might might become a thing in unity so i think it's definitely a good thing to learn it looks like the after the three months it costs 15 a month which uh you know seems very reasonable um if you're if you're using it, you're getting a lot of content out of it. So cool. My thing of the show is dig.ccmixter.org. So CC Mixer is a site that has a ton of different audio resources.
进入其他类型的，你知道，视觉效果，如果你必须做交互式图表之类的，可能会在 Unity 中成为一种趋势。所以我认为这绝对是一个值得学习的好东西。看起来三个月后每月收费 15 美元，这，你知道，看起来非常合理。如果你正在使用它，你从中获得了大量内容。太酷了。我的节目推荐是 dig.ccmixter.org。所以 CC Mixer 是一个拥有大量不同音频资源的网站。
And dig.ccmixter is a bunch of free resources. So if you're making a YouTube video, if you're making a youtube video for making a video game in unity if you want to take the background music that came with the uh with the unity uh uh you know starter pack and replace it with something else um you can just go and grab uh any of these uh um music uh songs and you can put them anywhere you know as long as some of them are attribution licensed so you know in the credits of your game or your video or in the comments the description of your video you have to give a shout out I mean which you should be doing anyways but But other than that, they're totally free to use. And there's a ton of content.
而 dig.ccmixter 是一堆免费资源。所以如果你正在制作 YouTube 视频，如果你正在制作 YouTube 视频，为了在 Unity 中制作游戏，如果你想把 Unity 入门包里自带的背景音乐替换成其他东西，你可以直接去抓取任何这些音乐歌曲，你可以把它们放在任何地方，你知道，只要其中一些是署名许可的，所以你知道，在你的游戏或视频的制作人员名单中，或者在你的视频描述的评论中，你必须表示感谢。我的意思是，无论如何你都应该这样做。但除此之外，它们完全可以免费使用。而且内容非常丰富。
They just hit their one million mark or one million folks have used at least one song from there, which is pretty incredible. And, you know, it's a great resource. I love things like this and Free Sound and other sort of sites that have tons of media for you to use for your own projects. That's pretty cool.
他们刚刚达到了 100 万的里程碑，或者说 100 万人使用了那里至少一首歌，这非常不可思议。而且，你知道，这是一个很棒的资源。我喜欢像这样的东西，还有 Free Sound 和其他一些拥有大量媒体供你用于自己项目的网站。这太酷了。
I guess that dovetails in with the previous suggestions when you make your game and you want some cool music and you can, yeah. Yeah, exactly. By the end of this, if you are furloughed, which again, heart goes out to you all, but you could use some of that time to make a pretty cool first-person shooter, learn some new tech. So not building on the previous two, I have something completely different, which is physicstravelguide.com. And I've always had this sort of weird passing interest in physics.
我想这与之前的建议相吻合，当你制作游戏并想要一些很酷的音乐时，你可以，是的。是的，完全正确。到此结束时，如果你被停薪留职了，再次重申，我为你们所有人感到难过，但你可以利用这段时间制作一个相当酷的第一人称射击游戏，学习一些新技术。所以，不基于前两个，我有一个完全不同的，那就是 physicstravelguide.com。我一直对物理学有一种奇怪的、一闪而过的兴趣。
I've never been able to get into the rigor of it. You know, I studied it and I guess a little bit in high school and in college. And I never really got into sort of the deep physics or whatever, theoretical physics and those kinds of things. But I found this website pretty good. And reading the explanation, it's like something I guess I never knew was missing, which is you get these, which is what I would give. So I won't try to for any of them. You get the sort of like armchair quarterback explanation of physics from your friend, which often leaves some to be desired. You could search whatever you're interested in in Wikipedia and probably be overwhelmed by things you don't understand
我从来没能深入研究它。你知道，我学习过它，我想在高中和大学里学过一点。我从来没有真正深入研究过所谓的深层物理学，或者理论物理学以及这类东西。但我发现这个网站相当不错。阅读它的解释，就像我猜我从未意识到缺少的东西，也就是你得到的这些，这就是我会给出的。所以我不会尝试任何一个。你从你的朋友那里得到了那种“扶手椅四分卫”式的物理学解释，这通常不尽如人意。你可以在维基百科上搜索任何你感兴趣的东西，并可能被你不理解的东西所淹没
or complexity, which is what I often find for math and physics. And so this website tries to take a variety of topics, allow you to sort of look in whatever you're interested in, and then explains it somewhere in the middle. So it tries to be rigorous, but it gives you sort of an intuitive explanation. So something that just like, oh, okay, I get that that kind of makes sense. And then they try to give you a sort of more formal and then the fully sort of abstract with formulas and everything. But they also give you
或者复杂性，这是我经常在数学和物理学中发现的。所以这个网站试图采取各种主题，让你查看任何你感兴趣的东西，然后在中间某个地方解释它。所以它试图严谨，但它给你一种直观的解释。所以就像，哦，好的，我明白了，那有点道理。然后他们试图给你一种更正式的，然后是完全抽象的，带有公式和一切的。但他们也给你
a bunch of links to follow up on and all of that. And they've got tons of articles here on just, you know, all sorts of things about quantum mechanics. Here's Maxwell's equation, Schrodinger's equation. And there's brief, very sort of simple to understand high level stuff. There's, you know, what what where to go from there. Like, how does it relate to the rest of physics? I found this a really interesting resource. You know, I haven't sat here and read all of it, but I do find every so often I come across some idea and I'm thinking about it.
一堆后续链接等等。他们这里有大量关于量子力学的文章。这是麦克斯韦方程，薛定谔方程。而且有简短的、非常容易理解的高层内容。有，你知道，从那里去哪里。比如，它与物理学的其余部分有什么关系？我发现这是一个非常有趣的资源。你知道，我没有坐在这里读完所有内容，但我确实发现每隔一段时间我就会遇到一些想法，我在思考它。
I don't know why. And just wondering, you know, I wonder how that works. And here's a way to go look it up. There's so much good content here there's also just looking at it i'm like i have no idea what that is and like click it and then i get uh oh okay well at least now i i didn't know i knew that before but uh that's pretty cool yeah i mean this is awesome yeah i mean i could easily uh i know what i'm doing today. Yeah, I mean, this covers everything. Yeah, so things like magnetic monopoles. And do they exist?
我不知道为什么。只是想知道，我想知道那是怎么运作的。这里有一个去查找它的方法。这里有这么多好的内容，我也只是看着它，我想我不知道那是什么，然后点击它，然后我得到，哦，好的，好吧，至少现在我知道了，我之前不知道我知道那个，但这太酷了。是的，我的意思是这太棒了。是的，我的意思是，我可以轻松地，我知道我今天要做什么。是的，我的意思是，这涵盖了一切。是的，所以像磁单极子这样的东西。它们存在吗？
Why would they be important if they don't exist or do exist? Yeah, it's cool stuff. Yeah, you have this whole equation section. They talk about all these different ways of solving problems. Physics is one of those things that has sort of puzzled me when I think about it. It seems like throughout my career, various physics things have always come up, like topics just from the news or from someone's idle thoughts, and we'll bring it up in the office,
如果它们不存在或存在，为什么它们很重要？是的，这是很酷的东西。是的，你有这个完整的方程部分。他们谈论所有这些解决问题的不同方法。物理学是当我思考它时让我感到困惑的事情之一。似乎在我的整个职业生涯中，各种物理学的东西总是出现，比如来自新闻或某人闲暇想法的话题，我们会在办公室里提出来，
which is one of the things I don't think comes up as much anymore. But, you know, it's one of those things that is a recurring theme where I don't need to know any physics to be able to do my job whatsoever presently. But it's something that I find that people who tend to do programming and stuff and be into it and like me also have a sort of passing interest. So I guess there's some similarity there. And it's one of those kind of quirky things that I guess there's no real reason why they need to be related but I find that they often are yeah I think it makes sense I mean I think the the at the end of the day the physics is kind of like what people what computer scientists did before there were computer scientists right so I mean a lot of us like to build stuff and simulate things. And now we can work sort of in the world of bits. But before, when there was only the world like to learn more about which is the sort of rigorous formal computer science uh theorem proving and we i'm
这是我认为现在不再那么常出现的事情之一。但是，你知道，这是反复出现的主题之一，我目前完全不需要知道任何物理学就能完成我的工作。但我发现那些倾向于做编程之类的事情，并且沉迷于它，像我一样的人，也有某种一闪而过的兴趣。所以我猜那里有一些相似之处。这是那种古怪的事情之一，我猜没有真正的理由说明它们为什么需要相关，但我发现它们经常相关。是的，我认为这说得通。我的意思是，我认为归根结底，物理学有点像计算机科学家在有计算机科学家之前所做的事情，对吧？所以我的意思是，我们很多人喜欢构建东西和模拟东西。现在我们可以在比特的世界里工作。但在以前，当只有世界的时候，就像学习更多关于什么是严谨的形式化计算机科学定理证明，我们，我
sure we've probably talked about uh various of languages used for this and before one is c o q is that coke or cock i don't know um but another one is the lean theorem prover. And as soon as I try reading it, I instantly kind of nope my way out. I think we've talked about Agda before, too. And I think Agda is pretty similar. Maybe not. I don't know. See, I don't even know enough about this to know. This is wild. What is this? So this lean theorem prover is one of these things where you try to take a theorem and through a series of I guess you would call them transformations. I don't know. I need to kind of go all the way through it again. It's on my maybe bucket list is too strong, but it's on
确定我们可能谈论过用于此的各种语言，之前一个是 Coq，那是 Coke 还是 Cock，我不知道。但另一个是 Lean 定理证明器。一旦我尝试阅读它，我立刻就放弃了。我想我们也谈论过 Agda。我想 Agda 也差不多。也许不是。我不知道。你看，我甚至对这个了解不够，不知道这是什么。这太疯狂了。这是什么？所以这个 Lean 定理证明器是那种你试图通过一系列，我想你会称之为转换的东西来证明一个定理。我不知道。我需要再次完整地经历它。它在我的，也许“愿望清单”这个词太强烈了，但它在
my list of things to one day learn about is to sort of take a set of transformations and prove a statement. So you might say that like the inverse of an inverse of a value is equal to the value itself, right? So you say like if I invert a value and invert it back, it's itself. So like, but why? How? Like how do you prove that? Like what is the sequence of steps to go through to explain that? Or the you know rule of what is it commutivity or associative rule like these rules in mathematics like how do you say that a plus b is equal to b plus a like how do we know that that's universally true how would you prove to a computer that this is uh something that it should take for granted um you know as a human we know we trust other people have done it but if you have a computer which has a set of i guess a language for describing what things are
我的清单上，有一天要学习的东西，就是采取一系列转换并证明一个陈述。所以你可能会说，一个值的逆的逆等于值本身，对吧？所以你说，如果我反转一个值并把它反转回来，它就是它本身。所以，但是为什么？怎么做？你怎么证明这一点？比如，解释这一点的步骤序列是什么？或者，你知道，什么是交换律或结合律，比如数学中的这些规则，比如你怎么说 A 加 B 等于 B 加 A，我们怎么知道那是普遍正确的？你怎么向计算机证明这是一个它应该认为理所当然的事情？你知道，作为人类，我们知道我们信任其他人已经做到了。但如果你有一台计算机，它有一套，我猜是一种用于描述什么东西在基础层面上是
true at a base level and you prove enough of those base level things and and link them to each other in a certain way the computer can go yes you have shown that this must be true now oh i see so uh this natural number oh sorry yeah this graph is is doing is trying to do that so this yeah so this natural number game which is my link will link it in the show notes uh presently it's it's uh i think getting it with for some reason having some hiccups it wasn't working so great for me has a sequence of things to go through teaching you uh i guess a variant of the lean theorem prover, which is one of the tools people use to do this kind of work by taking you through the steps of getting through sort of proving addition and how addition works and why it works. And going
真实的语言，并且你证明了足够多的那些基础层面的东西，并以某种方式将它们链接在一起，计算机可以去，“是的，你已经证明这一定是真的了。”哦，我明白了。所以，这个自然数，哦，抱歉，是的，这个图表正在尝试做那个。所以这个，是的，所以这个自然数游戏，这是我的链接，我会在节目笔记中链接它，目前，它，我想，因为某种原因出现了一些小故障，它对我来说运行得不是很好，有一系列的事情要经历，教你，我猜是 Lean 定理证明器的一个变体，这是人们用来做这种工作的工具之一，通过带你经历证明加法以及加法是如何工作的，以及为什么它能工作。并去
to like I was saying, like that, I always forget the rules, associativity and commutivity. And they have a sequence of learning steps laid out in a graph of one way you might go through the dependencies and build upon each other in your understanding while also teaching you how to do this theorem proving. And I thought it was a pretty cool approach for something that I've long wanted to understand.
像我说的，像那个，我总是忘记规则，结合律和交换律。他们有一系列学习步骤，布置在一个图表中，关于你可能经历依赖关系的一种方式，并在你的理解中建立在彼此之上，同时教你如何做这个定理证明。我觉得对于我长期以来一直想理解的东西，这是一个非常酷的方法。
And maybe this is helpful to you if you've also wanted to learn about theorem proving. Yeah, this is awesome. Yeah. I've never been, uh, you know, into, into theorem proving, but, uh, my, my PhD advisor, he's famous for saying, uh, theory is worthless. That's like his thing.
也许如果你也想学习定理证明，这对你有帮助。是的，这太棒了。是的。我从来没有，你知道，沉迷于定理证明，但是，我的博士导师，他以说“理论是毫无价值的”而闻名。那是他的口头禅。
Um, you know, I think that, that obviously that's like a really extreme view. I mean, it's something that only someone who is a professor in neural networks would say. But I think that without it, you can't really get started. I think a lot of the stuff that we take for granted, as you said, is because some people took something that we observed and were able to construct a pattern and generalize it. Yeah, this is totally awesome. And it actually has a really nice tutorial and it walks you through like starting with the identity, like proving that X equals X.
嗯，你知道，我认为这显然是一个非常极端的观点。我的意思是，这只有作为神经网络教授的人才会说。但我认为没有它，你真的无法开始。我认为我们认为理所当然的很多东西，正如你所说，是因为有些人观察到了我们观察到的东西，并能够构建一个模式并将其概括。是的，这太棒了。而且它实际上有一个非常好的教程，它引导你从恒等式开始，比如证明 X 等于 X。
And then, or I guess at that point, that's an observation. Yeah, this is cool. Man, between this and the last thing, that's basically gonna be my entire day now. Hey, guys, we're going to take a little break to talk about University of California, Irvine's Division of Continuing Education. So this is a pretty cool program. They have a variety of different kind of certificates that you could acquire. They have things like Python, they have data science, they have machine learning. And these are things where, you know, if you didn't necessarily get, let's say, a degree in machine learning or you haven't worked as a machine learning engineer
然后，或者我猜在那一点上，那是一个观察。是的，这很酷。天哪，在这件事和上一件事之间，那基本上将是我今天的一整天了。嘿，伙计们，我们要休息一下，谈谈加州大学欧文分校的继续教育部门。所以这是一个非常酷的项目。他们有各种各样的证书，你可以获得。他们有像 Python、数据科学、机器学习这样的东西。这些是，你知道，如果你不一定获得了，比如说，机器学习学位，或者你没有作为机器学习工程师工作
for a bunch of years, this is a way to sort of get a lot of that knowledge, a lot of that expertise. And, you know, I know Patrick and I, we've both done a bunch of courses online. And so it's a really good way to sort of boost, you know, your knowledge and your skills in a particular area. Yeah, I mean, I did tons of online classes when I first started working. And, you know, for me, being part of a class, I mean, it's always interesting, but the curriculum, the self-paced stuff, it works great sometimes. But sometimes having a here's what we're doing each week, marching through their curriculum and going through it, it's very similar to how, you know, just a normal university class works.
很多年，这是一种获得很多那种知识、很多那种专业技能的方法。而且，你知道，我知道 Patrick 和我，我们都做过很多在线课程。所以这是一个提升，你知道，你在特定领域的知识和技能的好方法。是的，我的意思是，我刚开始工作时做了大量的在线课程。而且，你知道，对我来说，成为班级的一部分，我的意思是，它总是很有趣，但课程，自定进度的东西，有时效果很好。但有时有一个“这是我们每周要做的事情”，按照他们的课程表进行，这非常类似于，你知道，正常的大学课程是如何运作的。
In fact, you know, feeling like it's almost exactly the same is just a comfortable thing, a good way to learn. And learning from professors who, you know, that's their thing. They teach, they help others to learn and having access to it, doing the assignments. It really helped me go from, you know, where my undergraduate left off to, you know, to just kind of bootstrapping into more specifics, higher level things, things that were more pertinent to my job at the time. You know, I highly recommend people taking classes, continuing education from a college. Yep. Yep. Yeah. I think getting it through a university is actually really, really stellar. I mean, it's really awesome that universities are starting to get into this. And, you know,
事实上，你知道，感觉它几乎完全一样是一件舒服的事情，一种很好的学习方式。并且向教授学习，你知道，那是他们的专长。他们教书，他们帮助别人学习，并且能够接触到它，做作业。它真的帮助我从，你知道，我的本科毕业的地方，到，你知道，只是引导进入更多的细节，更高级的东西，与我当时的工作更相关的东西。你知道，我强烈推荐人们参加课程，来自大学的继续教育。是的。是的。是的。我认为通过大学获得它实际上非常非常出色。我的意思是，大学开始涉足这个领域真的很棒。而且，你知道，
that there's going to be sort of quality lectures and professors there's there's you know there's a very strong brand behind any any sort of major university and you know uc reminds one of the top universities for cs so um so they they you know they've been around since about 1962 i think and they uh you know they have uh you know they've been around a long time they've been doing you know they've been around a long time. They've been doing, you know, they've been teaching a long time. They've been teaching online a long time. And so it's a good place to to go and get this kind of education. Yeah. If you're interested, I think they're still doing enrollment for some late classes for spring, but summer is upcoming. And as we've been talking about this whole episode,
将会有高质量的讲座和教授，你知道，任何主要大学背后都有一个非常强大的品牌，而且，你知道，加州大学欧文分校是计算机科学的顶尖大学之一，所以，嗯，他们，你知道，他们从 1962 年左右就开始了，我想，他们，你知道，他们有，你知道，他们存在了很长时间，他们一直在做，你知道，他们存在了很长时间。他们一直在做，你知道，他们一直在教书很长时间。他们一直在网上教书很长时间。所以这是一个去获得这种教育的好地方。是的。如果你感兴趣，我想他们仍然在为春季的一些晚课进行注册，但夏季即将到来。正如我们在这整期节目中一直在谈论的那样，
I mean, I think everyone has extra time at home these days. Oh, my gosh. If you're interested, you can check it out at CE.UCI.EDU slash programming throwdown. And we'll put the link in the show notes, of course. But once again, that's CE.UCI.EDu slash programming throwdown yeah and if you uh do sign up and take any courses you know we'd love to get feedback you know please write us in tell us what you think of it um you know we could pass it on to them but also for us it's really good to know um you know what you thought about that uh you know folks out there who are listening so all right back to the show uh now it's time for book of the show my book of the show is influence by robert cialdini um this is a really interesting book um i actually read it a while back um um but but it kind of stuck with me and um it goes through the thing I love about this book. So I recommended, um, um, another book by I think Scott Adams that was about influence, but that book was, um, written by someone who I guess so um they say a lot of you know
我的意思是，我认为每个人这些天在家里都有额外的时间。哦，天哪。如果你感兴趣，你可以在 CE.UCI.EDU/programmingthrowdown 查看。当然，我们会把链接放在节目笔记中。但再一次，那是 CE.UCI.EDU/programmingthrowdown。是的，如果你注册并参加任何课程，你知道，我们很乐意得到反馈，你知道，请写信告诉我们你的想法，嗯，我们可以把它传达给他们，但对我们来说，知道，你知道你对那个的想法，你知道正在听的各位，也是非常好的。好的，回到节目。现在是节目推荐书的时间。我的节目推荐书是罗伯特·西奥迪尼的《影响力》。这是一本非常有趣的书，嗯，我其实很久以前读过它，嗯，但它有点留在了我的脑海里，而且，嗯，它经历了，我喜欢这本书的地方。所以我推荐了，嗯，另一本我认为是斯科特·亚当斯写的关于影响力的书，但那本书是，嗯，由一个我猜，所以，嗯，他们说了很多，你知道，
the beginning at least they say a lot of things that are kind of obvious um but then they show actually this ties in well with um with our last news article um they kind of show why these things are what they are like they kind of explain the causality there. And then they start jumping into, you know, kind of more advanced topics and things that you wouldn't really expect. One of the things that really stood out for me was they said that if you, let's say you're in a traffic accident and so you're on the highway and let's say you have, I don't know, a broken arm or something, you know, someone just hit you from behind, you have a broken arm and let's say that person sped off. So, um, so you're in the, you're in a bad spot, right? So I said, one thing you should do is, is instead of like waving and trying to get all the car's attention at once, you should actually just stop a car or like pick
至少开头，他们说了很多有点显而易见的事情，但随后他们展示了，实际上这与我们上一篇新闻文章结合得很好，他们有点展示了为什么这些事情是它们现在的样子，就像他们解释了那里的因果关系。然后他们开始跳入，你知道，有点更高级的主题和你不真正期望的事情。真正让我印象深刻的一件事是，他们说，如果你，假设你发生了一起交通事故，所以你在高速公路上，假设你有一个，我不知道，骨折的手臂之类的，你知道，有人刚从后面撞了你，你有一个骨折的手臂，假设那个人开车跑了。所以，嗯，所以你处于，你处于一个糟糕的境地，对吧？所以我说，你应该做的一件事是，而不是像挥手试图同时引起所有汽车的注意，你应该实际上只是拦下一辆车，或者，你知道，挑选
one car and focus on them. Or, or imagine the same thing if you're in a line and and you're feeling like you're going to pass out or something um you pick one person in the line and you ask them directly for help and um the reason why is is um basically there's this sort of weird dynamic with influence where if someone isn't totally sure you're trying to influence them or somebody else then then nobody takes you seriously and so um if you pick one person even if that person doesn't help you by by sort of focusing on them and getting rejected by that person you immediately build like a ton of influence with the people right around them um and and so you know that
一辆车并专注于他们。或者，或者想象同样的事情，如果你在排队，你感觉你要晕倒了之类的，嗯，你挑选队伍中的一个人，你直接向他们寻求帮助，而且，嗯，原因基本上是，嗯，有一种关于影响力的奇怪动态，如果有人不完全确定你试图影响他们还是别人，那么没有人会认真对待你，所以，嗯，如果你挑选一个人，即使那个人没有帮助你，通过，你知道，专注于他们并被那个人拒绝，你立即在他们周围的人中建立了大量的影响力，而且，你知道，那
was just one thing i won't go through everything but it talks a lot about social science it explains like why uh you know car salesmen do what they do um explains you know both good and bad influence um and i thought the whole thing was really fascinating. I mean, I think especially for introverts, this is a must read because you can kind of see, you know, for extroverts and for people who are naturally have a lot of influence. You know, I think a lot of these things could come naturally or feel naturally, feel natural. But but for everyone else, you're just getting the information, being exposed to it is extraordinarily valuable. And now you can kind of see, now that I've read the book, I kind of see the attempt to influence in commercials and when people write sales pitches and all of that. You can kind of decompose it, deconstruct, using all of this theory that has come out of this book. So it's a bit of a heavy read. It's written for lay people like us. So you don't have to be a social scientist. It doesn't use a lot of complicated terminology. But, you know,
只是我不会经历所有事情的一件事，但它谈论了很多关于社会科学，它解释了为什么，嗯，你知道，汽车推销员做他们所做的事情，解释了，你知道，好的和坏的影响力，而且我认为整件事非常迷人。我的意思是，我认为特别是对于内向者来说，这是一本必读的书，因为你可以有点看到，你知道，对于外向者和那些天生有很大影响力的人。你知道，我认为很多这些事情可以自然地发生或感觉自然，感觉自然。但对于其他人来说，你只是在获取信息，接触到它，是非常有价值的。现在你可以有点看到，既然我已经读了这本书，我有点看到在广告中，以及当人们写销售推销词时，所有这些试图影响的行为。你可以有点分解它，解构它，使用所有从这本书中出来的理论。所以这是一本有点沉重的书。它是为像我们这样的外行写的。所以你不必成为社会科学家。它没有使用很多复杂的术语。但是，你知道，
it's a pretty deep dive. So keep that in mind. But, you know, now's a good time, hopefully, for a lot of folks to do some reading. And I think this is a good one to pick up. You've influenced me. I feel the need to to read this book about influence. All right. Although that's so meta. So this book must be working. So. Yeah. So my my book of the show is a science fiction book called Columbus Day, which is part of a series Expeditionary Force by Craig Allenson. And this, you know, I read a lot of science fiction and fantasy since the last time we've done book of the show. I had actually a pretty long list, but I picked this one.
这是一个相当深入的研究。所以记住这一点。但是，你知道，现在是一个好时机，希望对很多人来说，做一些阅读。而且我认为这是一个值得拿起的好书。你影响了我。我感到有必要去读这本关于影响力的书。好的。虽然那太元了。所以这本书一定在起作用。所以。是的。所以我的节目推荐书是一本名为《哥伦布日》的科幻小说，它是克雷格·阿伦森的《远征军》系列的一部分。而且这个，你知道，自从我们上次做节目推荐书以来，我读了很多科幻和奇幻小说。我其实有一个很长的清单，但我选了这个。
It's the most recent one I've read. And I really enjoyed this. It was a pretty lighthearted read. Well, a pretty easy read, not in not a sort of deep, deep sci fi book. But it had some interesting ideas, which is, you know, if the it doesn't spoil too much. I checked the Amazon review and it's listed as sort of the summary. But if Earth was invaded by sort of an alien species and then some other alien species came and, you know, did battle with them. And we sort of like, yay, there are saviors.
这是我读过的最新的一本。我真的很喜欢这个。这是一本相当轻松的读物。嗯，一本相当容易的读物，不是那种深奥的科幻书。但它有一些有趣的想法，也就是，你知道，如果，它没有剧透太多。我查了亚马逊评论，它被列为某种摘要。但如果地球被某种外星物种入侵，然后其他一些外星物种来了，并且，你知道，与他们战斗。而我们有点像，耶，他们是救世主。
They fought off the bad guys. We actually have no context for that. We don't know how or why they did what they did to sort of celebrate them as heroes makes sense, but could be wrong. And that if such people actually showed up, we don't know the grand scheme of species and aliens that would be out.
他们击退了坏人。我们实际上对此没有任何背景。我们不知道他们是如何或为什么做他们所做的事情，把他们当作英雄来庆祝是有道理的，但可能是错的。而且如果这样的人真的出现了，我们不知道物种和外星人的宏大计划会是什么。
So if someone showed up with vastly superior technology to us, we'd somewhat be subservient to them. But if we had a choice, we would have no broader context of the political scheme of where they came from. Like, who are their enemies? Are we allying ourselves with like, the really bad people of the universe? And like, are we going to become part of the, you know, axis of evil? Like, we don't, you wouldn't really know. And it's sort of an interesting topic that we always think of ourselves as like kind of knowing what's what and if somebody just you know it's fiction right but if someone sort of just popped into the sky there would be actually very little we would understand and
所以如果有人带着远超我们的技术出现，我们在某种程度上会沦为他们的附庸。但如果我们有选择权，我们对他们来自何处的政治体系将毫无背景认知。比如，谁是他们的敌人？我们是否在与宇宙中真正的恶人结盟？我们是否会成为所谓的“邪恶轴心”的一部分？我们真的无从知晓。这是一个很有趣的话题，我们总是自认为洞悉一切，但如果有人——当然这只是科幻小说——如果有人突然出现在天空中，我们实际上能理解的东西会非常少，而且
what we were able to be communicated about might be very limited. So we may not know the whole story. All you know is that they don't like the people who are trying to kill you. That's the only piece of information you have, right? Right. But the people trying to kill you, there are various levels of that, right? And so exactly what they, you can always spin it. But then if it gets spun, so they you know you can say oh they only were destroying large cities right maybe they were just trying to prevent uh you know make it less you a less
我们能沟通的内容可能非常有限。所以我们可能无法了解事情的全貌。你唯一知道的就是他们不喜欢那些试图杀死你的人。这是你拥有的唯一信息，对吧？没错。但那些试图杀死你的人，他们也分不同层级，对吧？所以他们到底……你总能美化它。但如果被美化了，你可以说，哦，他们只是在摧毁大城市，也许他们只是想阻止……你知道，让它成为一个不那么
valuable target um and so is that a kind-hearted thing to do or a terrible thing to do were they trying to help you are they trying to hurt you so yes you're right so if other people showed up and fought them off all we know is that they fought them. Yeah, we don't know. Are they the bad guys or the good guys? Should we go with them? Should we fight them? Yeah, that's usually start with something that happened on Earth, like, you know, that they want to, to explore, and they just want to get rid of basically all the names and the places. But it's really like something that could happen on Earth between countries. Or, or do they do they just start with a blank canvas and say, you know, I want planets made of sodium, and then they just start exploring a blank canvas and say you know i want planets made of sodium and then then they just start exploring all the implications of that yeah i mean i think it happens lots of
有价值的目标。那么这是一种善意的行为还是一种可怕的行为？他们是在试图帮助你还是伤害你？所以是的，你是对的，如果其他人出现并击退了他们，我们只知道他们确实进行了战斗。是的，我们不知道。他们是坏人还是好人？我们应该跟随他们吗？我们应该与他们战斗吗？是的，这通常始于地球上发生的事情，比如，你知道，他们想要探索，他们只是想去掉所有的名字和地点。但这真的就像地球上各国之间可能发生的事情。或者，他们是否只是从一张白纸开始，说，你知道，我想要由钠构成的行星，然后他们就开始探索一张白纸，说，你知道，我想要由钠构成的行星，然后他们就开始探索所有相关的含义。是的，我的意思是，我认为这种情况以很多
different ways if you're curious about this i did stumble across a random reddit the other day um which is the world building reddit so uh if you go to reddit.com slash r slash world building um they actually have a reddit where people give maps for places they've invented. People give feedback, ask questions. What do you think about this? Exactly that. If the world was not mostly silica based sand, but sodium everywhere, like what would be different?
不同的方式发生。如果你对此感到好奇，我前几天偶然发现了一个随机的 Reddit 帖子，嗯，是世界构建（world building）的 Reddit 版块。所以，如果你去 reddit.com/r/worldbuilding，他们实际上有一个 Reddit 版块，人们会在那里提供他们发明的地点的地图。人们会给出反馈，提出问题。你觉得这个怎么样？正是如此。如果世界不是主要由硅基沙子构成，而是到处都是钠，那会有什么不同？
And, you know, they kind of riff off each other, help each other think through the implications and generally just, you know, sort of help out creative people with trying to think through what would happen. Cool subreddit to check out. Yeah, it sounds awesome. It's time for. Oh, well, talking at first, I was going to skip the show, but I forgot I haven't been driving in the car. But, you know, I still find that I haven't been actually reading the books either. I found downtime.
而且，你知道，他们会互相启发，帮助彼此思考其中的含义，通常只是，你知道，帮助有创造力的人思考会发生什么。很酷的子版块，值得一看。是的，听起来棒极了。是时候了。哦，好吧，一开始说话时，我打算跳过这个节目，但我忘了我最近没怎么开车。但是，你知道，我仍然发现我也没有在看书。我找到了空闲时间。
I've still been listening to to Audible. And so Audible, of course, is one of the people who help sponsor our show. And if you go to Audible trial dot com slash programming throw down, you can get your first book free. You could get I don't I didn't check to see if they have influence, but that's where I listen to this Columbus Day book. And I don't drive in the commute, but I still find that I use Audible. Just, you know, the other day I was I think was vacuuming and I put on headphones and was listening to that while I was vacuuming because I guess I'm a weirdo. But I wanted to keep making progress on my on my books. So if you're interested in checking out listening to books and you haven't yet, you could go to audibletrial.com slash programming throwdown. Get yourself a free book.
我一直在听 Audible。当然，Audible 是赞助我们节目的伙伴之一。如果你去 audibletrial.com/programmingthrowdown，你可以免费获得第一本书。你可以获得——我没查他们是否有《影响力》（Influence）这本书，但我就是在那儿听的《哥伦布日》（Columbus Day）。我不开车通勤，但我仍然发现我经常使用 Audible。只是，你知道，前几天我在吸尘，我戴上耳机，一边吸尘一边听，因为我大概是个怪人。但我还是想在我的书上取得进展。所以如果你有兴趣尝试听书，但还没试过，你可以去 audibletrial.com/programmingthrowdown。给自己弄本免费的书。
Also help out the show. Yeah. Yeah. Influence is I read or listen to influence on audible as well. OK. Yeah. I think I think for me, what my routine has been basically in the the evening i'll just lay down and and uh i actually i got these uh um i got a new phone i got the pixel i don't know whatever it is i think i think
也能支持一下节目。是的。是的，《影响力》我也在 Audible 上读过或听过。好的。是的，我想对我来说，我的日常基本上是晚上躺下，然后……我实际上买了这些……我买了一部新手机，我买了 Pixel，我不知道是什么型号，我想我想
i got the three it wasn't the very latest one so yeah i got pixel three it came with um uh earbuds and in the past i've not liked earbuds they always kind of fall out of the ear or you have the weird hoop around the ear. But these ones have a really interesting design where basically they shrink wrapped like a thick piece of plastic around the beginning of the wire coming out of the earbud. And then they took that wire and they like looped it and put it back, threaded it back through the earbud. And you can actually control the size of that loop. And that loop actually, you know, presses very gently against like the inside of your ear and kind of keeps it in place. And so for the first time, I feel like I can have earbuds, I can even like run with them and everything, and they're pretty comfortable.
我买了 Pixel 3，它不是最新的那款，所以是的，我买了 Pixel 3，它附带了……嗯，耳塞。过去我不喜欢耳塞，它们总是从耳朵里掉出来，或者耳朵周围有个奇怪的环。但这些耳塞的设计非常有趣，基本上他们用厚塑料把耳塞线出来的部分像热缩管一样包起来。然后他们把那根线绕成一个圈，穿回耳塞里。你实际上可以控制那个圈的大小。那个圈实际上，你知道，会非常轻柔地压在你的耳廓内侧，并把它固定住。所以这是我第一次觉得我可以戴耳塞，我甚至可以戴着它们跑步什么的，而且它们非常舒适。
So what I've been doing is basically laying down. and and that way if you kind of roll over you don't you know kind of squish like you know the the headphone against your ear and just kind of having some time to like kind of just close your eyes and listen to a book um especially with um you know all of us working from home you know we're not um you know i just i find myself looking at screens way more because i'm either you know helping out like the kids and they're they're doing something on a screen or i'm on a screen and so this is just a a good opportunity to not have to like read something or really focus your eyes on something so yeah and so you can totally get Influence for free If you go to audibletrial.com Slash programmingthrowdown
所以我一直在做的是基本上躺下。这样如果你翻身，你就不会，你知道，把耳机压在耳朵上，只是花点时间闭上眼睛听书。尤其是，你知道，我们都在家办公，你知道，我们不是……你知道，我发现我盯着屏幕的时间多了很多，因为我要么在帮孩子们，他们在屏幕上做些什么，要么我自己就在屏幕前。所以这只是一个好机会，不用去读什么东西，或者真的让眼睛专注于某样东西。所以是的，你可以完全免费获得《影响力》，如果你去 audibletrial.com/programmingthrowdown。
Also if you want to support Support us And you already have an audible Or you don't want to get an audible account You can support us directly on Patreon Also if you are a member On Patreon you get the Patreon Stream which is
另外，如果你想支持我们，而你已经有了 Audible 账号，或者你不想注册 Audible 账号，你可以直接在 Patreon 上支持我们。另外，如果你是 Patreon 的会员，你可以获得 Patreon 流媒体，也就是
As much higher bandwidth so that part is nice um but yeah check us out on patreon and uh and uh we really appreciate all the support okay now it's not too early to say that it's time for tool of the show tool of the show my tool of the show is vcpkg or or I don't know what that's supposed to actually be. Let me see. Yeah, it's vcpkg. It's a sum from Microsoft. It's a C++ library manager.
带宽更高，所以那部分很不错。嗯，但请在 Patreon 上关注我们，我们非常感谢所有的支持。好的，现在说“本期工具”时间还不算太早。本期工具，我的工具是 vcpkg，或者我不知道它到底应该怎么读。让我看看。是的，是 vcpkg。它是微软出的。它是一个 C++ 库管理器。
It works really well. So basically, if you program in, let's say, JavaScript or TypeScript, then you're definitely familiar with NPM or YARN. And so these are package managers. You can basically say, you know, NPM install React. And it will just go through, install React, install all the dependencies. It'll do all the work for you so that in your code, you can just type, you know, import React and it's just done.
它工作得非常好。所以基本上，如果你用 JavaScript 或 TypeScript 编程，那么你肯定熟悉 NPM 或 YARN。这些是包管理器。你可以基本上说，你知道，npm install React。它就会去安装 React，安装所有的依赖项。它会为你完成所有的工作，这样在你的代码中，你只需要输入，你知道，import React，就完成了。
You don't have to worry about, you know, what it took to make that happen. You know, for Java, there was Maven, which did this. For Python, there's Anaconda or Pip. But for C++, you know, there's been a variety of different tools. And I did a quick survey myself, there was I think one called Conan. There's one actually that Ethereum uses. I don't remember the name of it. But, but vcpkg from Microsoft seemed to be the best. And it worked really well. It's it's even though it's from Microsoft from Microsoft, you don't have to be on Windows to use it. But basically you install this program
你不需要担心，你知道，为了实现这一点需要做什么。你知道，对于 Java，有 Maven，它就是做这个的。对于 Python，有 Anaconda 或 Pip。但对于 C++，你知道，一直有各种不同的工具。我自己做了一个快速调查，我想有一个叫 Conan。还有一个实际上是 Ethereum 使用的。我不记得名字了。但是，微软的 vcpkg 似乎是最好的。而且它工作得非常好。尽管它是微软出的，但你不需要在 Windows 上使用它。基本上你安装这个程序，
and then it's just vcpkg install whatever the C++ library is. It could be Boost, it could be Protobuf, it could be SDL, whatever you need. After you do that, then you have to be using CMake for this to work. But then in your CMake file for your project, you pass in this vcpkg toolchain file
然后就是 vcpkg install 任何 C++ 库。可以是 Boost，可以是 Protobuf，可以是 SDL，任何你需要的东西。做完这些之后，你必须使用 CMake 才能让它工作。但在你的项目 CMake 文件中，你传入这个 vcpkg 工具链文件，
and then you're good to go. So you could just bang include boost and it's there. So I thought it worked pretty well. With C++ it's difficult because it's much more open-ended in terms of the build system and everything. But this struck a good compromise where it
然后就可以了。所以你可以直接 #include boost，它就在那里了。所以我认为它工作得很好。对于 C++ 来说这很难，因为它在构建系统等方面更加开放。但这达成了一个很好的妥协，它
forces you to use CMake but it's not holding your hand too much there. And on the flip side it has a lot of packages and really good support. Yeah, this is pretty cool. I'm going to check it out. I always struggle with C++
强制你使用 CMake，但它不会在那方面过多地干预你。另一方面，它有很多包，而且支持非常好。是的，这很酷。我要去看看。我总是为 C++
and getting libraries and dependencies. And do you include the source in your source? Do you have everyone build their own libraries? It's always such a mess. Yeah, I mean, I try to include the source in the source. So if you look at Eternal Terminal, or any of the projects I have, there's an external folder, and there's a bunch of Git submodules in there. But for some things like protobuf, it's just not practical. And so I relied on this, and so far it's worked pretty well. Well, keeping with not recommending informational books or tools, I'm recommending a game. That game is Dead Cells. I guess most people probably heard about it, but I'm late to it.
以及获取库和依赖项而苦恼。你是把源码包含在你的源码里吗？你是让每个人都自己构建库吗？这总是一团糟。是的，我的意思是，我尝试把源码包含在源码里。所以如果你看 Eternal Terminal，或者我拥有的任何项目，都有一个 external 文件夹，里面有一堆 Git 子模块。但对于像 Protobuf 这样的一些东西，这并不实际。所以我依赖这个，到目前为止它工作得很好。好吧，继续不推荐信息类书籍或工具，我推荐一个游戏。那个游戏是《死亡细胞》（Dead Cells）。我想大多数人可能听说过，但我接触得比较晚。
This is a roguelite Castlevania-inspired action platformer. Okay, I cheated. I read from their website because I didn't know how to describe it. So if you've ever played a Castlevania game and sort of doing the 2D platforming and also having things closed off that you don't know how to get to yet. Yeah, this has kind of those elements. It also has roguelike elements that, you know, you make some amount of progress, but also like if you die, you kind of lose some of the stuff. And I really find it pretty cool. And I first started started playing it although it had been out for a while on other platforms on the um on my ipad and there it's a little tough because some
这是一个受《恶魔城》启发的 Roguelite 动作平台游戏。好吧，我作弊了。我读了他们的网站，因为我不知道该怎么描述它。所以如果你玩过《恶魔城》游戏，做那种 2D 平台跳跃，并且还有一些你还不知道怎么进入的封闭区域。是的，它有这些元素。它也有 Roguelike 元素，你知道，你取得了一定进展，但如果你死了，你会失去一些东西。我真的觉得它很酷。我第一次开始玩它的时候，尽管它在其他平台上已经出了一段时间了，是在我的 iPad 上。在那里有点难，因为有些
parts require kind of a lot of precision um but i still thoroughly enjoyed it the art style is pretty cool the the kind of atmosphere of the game is really nice and the awesome thing is it's available um on you know i think like the xbox playstation the switch i know it's on ios um it didn't look like it's on android yet but most people probably have at least one of many of those things uh on the pc as well i believe it's on steam um and so if you haven't checked it out before and that description sounded interesting or you go look it up and see the video, it sounds interesting and check it out. But I really like that game. It's really cool.
部分需要很高的精确度，但我仍然非常喜欢它。艺术风格很酷，游戏的氛围也很好。最棒的是它可以在……你知道，我想像 Xbox、PlayStation、Switch 上都有，我知道它在 iOS 上有，看起来它在 Android 上还没有，但大多数人可能至少有其中之一。在 PC 上我也相信它在 Steam 上有。所以如果你以前没看过，而且那个描述听起来很有趣，或者你去查一下看看视频，它听起来很有趣，去看看吧。但我真的很喜欢那个游戏。它真的很酷。
I definitely have. So I have not won or made tons of progress, but I do keep playing it. Cool. So it's it's it's a Castlevania game. So you're kind of running around like slashing at things. Yeah, that's right. Yep. And you have various weapons you can switch out or
我绝对玩过。所以我还没有通关或取得巨大进展，但我一直在玩。酷。所以它是一个《恶魔城》游戏。所以你基本上是在到处跑，砍杀东西。是的，没错。是的。而且你有各种可以切换的武器，或者
change or customize your person and you kind of unlock better stuff as you make progress kind of like a rogue oh okay cool check it out there was one called uh wayward souls which was like a um it sounds similar but uh um one thing i didn't like about that game is it was, do you remember those, remember like, you know, like the original Zelda? How it was kind of like a top down, but not really. It's also kind of from the side too, right? Isometric? I think it's isometric.
改变或自定义你的角色，随着你的进展，你会解锁更好的东西，有点像 Rogue。哦，好的，酷，去看看。有一个叫《Wayward Souls》的游戏，它像是一个……听起来很相似，但有一点我不喜欢那个游戏，它是……你还记得那些吗？记得像最初的《塞尔达传说》吗？它是那种俯视角的，但又不完全是。它也有一点侧视角的，对吧？等轴测视角（Isometric）？我想是等轴测视角。
Is it isometric? Yeah, it could be. Yeah, so this, the Wayward Souls was isometric. And so that made it kind of difficult to judge the distances. So it sounds like the dead cells is like a platform or like a side view it's like a side yeah exactly yes yeah it might be easier um cool yeah i'll check that out i'll probably pick that up i'm a huge huge gamer so i'm actually surprised i'd heard of that so i'm gonna oh really okay it's on it's on mobile
是等轴测视角吗？是的，可能是。是的，所以这个《Wayward Souls》是等轴测视角的。这使得判断距离变得有点困难。所以听起来《死亡细胞》像是一个平台游戏，或者像侧视角的，它是侧视角的，是的，完全正确。是的，它可能更容易。酷，是的，我会去看看。我可能会买下来。我是个超级大玩家，所以我很惊讶我听说过那个。所以我打算……哦，真的吗？好的，它在移动端上。
you said uh i don't know if it's on android i looked i couldn't it didn't look like it was but it's on nearly everything else i actually don't know why it's not on android oh okay got it so since you already just said you have a pixel you might be uh you might be left out oh it's coming on june 3rd says android on june all right cool maybe i'll pick it up on pc so for our our topic, we decided to do something a little bit different. So I had this idea and I kind of looked and I became enamored with it. So if everyone hates it, you can send your hate mail to Jason. People say they can't tell our voices apart, so they don't know who's talking.
你说……我不知道它是否在 Android 上。我查了，我没看到它有，但它几乎在所有其他平台上都有。我其实不知道为什么它不在 Android 上。哦，好的，明白了。既然你刚才说你有 Pixel，你可能会被排除在外。哦，它说 6 月 3 日在 Android 上发布。好吧，酷，也许我会在 PC 上买。那么对于我们的主题，我们决定做点不同的事情。我有了这个想法，我有点迷上了它。所以如果每个人都讨厌它，你可以把你的仇恨邮件发给 Jason。人们说他们分不清我们的声音，所以他们不知道是谁在说话。
So I thought, you know, we did 100 episodes. I didn't want to do something super celebratory or patting ourselves on the back because just because we're dumb enough not to quit doesn't mean that we've done something great. But what I did say is it's been nine. So our first episode was in 2011. And people throughout the years have written us and told us how funny it is to go back and listen to early topics. But I wanted to take some of the show notes that we had from our early episodes. I don't know how many we're going to do. We'll just sort of see. And we'll sort of take turns or do it together and just sort of read through some of the topics and talk about
所以我心想，你知道，我们做了 100 期节目。我不想搞什么盛大的庆祝活动或自我吹捧，因为仅仅因为我们笨到没有放弃，并不意味着我们做了什么伟大的事情。但我确实说的是，已经九年了。所以我们的第一期节目是在 2011 年。多年来，人们写信告诉我们，回头去听早期的主题是多么有趣。但我想要拿出我们早期节目的一些节目笔记。我不知道我们要讲多少。我们走着瞧。我们会轮流或者一起读一些主题，谈谈
how times have changed or how things have changed. And, you know, just sort of a little bit of a look back. And funny because, you know, we're talking at the beginning even you know video conferencing and how it just takes time for a culture to to sort of grow up around it um and so i'm pretty sure we'll find some uh some insights here about what things have or haven't changed maybe some languages have gone and maybe some languages see are never going to go away um but we're going to take it away so so i'm going to take it with the very first one, Jason, I'm taking it all the way back to February of 2011. Oh, sorry. March of 2011.
时代是如何变迁的，或者事情是如何改变的。而且，你知道，只是一个小小的回顾。很有趣，因为，你知道，我们在开头谈论视频会议，以及文化围绕它成熟起来需要时间。所以我很确定我们会在这里发现一些关于哪些事情改变了或没改变的见解。也许有些语言已经消失了，也许有些语言永远不会消失。但我们要开始了。所以我要从第一期开始，Jason，我要把它带回到 2011 年 2 月。哦，抱歉。2011 年 3 月。
Oh, sorry. You're going to tell people what they tell people is, is, is Patrick's agreed to do the odd episodes and I've agreed to the even, and we've also agreed not to read the other one. So this is going to be a surprise to me and mine are going to be pretty surprising to Patrick too. Yep. Okay. So, so episode one. So here it goes. So the first thing that I have in the show notes that we talked about was the fail overflow PS3 hack, which we warn people not to watch the video that we posted a link to because we didn't want someone to get into trouble for
哦，抱歉。你要告诉人们的是，Patrick 同意做奇数期，我同意做偶数期，我们也同意不读对方的笔记。所以这对我是个惊喜，我的笔记对 Patrick 来说也会很惊喜。是的。好的。所以，第一期。开始了。所以我在节目笔记中提到的第一件事是 Fail0verflow 的 PS3 破解，我们警告人们不要看我们发布链接的视频，因为我们不想让某人惹上麻烦……
all the takeout. Oh man, I remember that. So actually so actually my uh because of that oh no no never mind there was actually an unrelated hack and a bunch of remember when when the playstation was the store was hacked and all of our credit cards got leaked out oh yes but i think this is different this is hacking the actual hardware so the next one is going to be, we know it's there, but it's coming. So this was, we talked about Bitcoin. Yes, we talked about Bitcoin in March of 2011. And yes, if we had bought $100 of it, even today, I think we would still have millions of dollars. So Bitcoin, Jason, what do you think about Bitcoin?
所有的外卖。天哪，我记得那个。所以实际上……因为那个……哦不，没关系。其实有一个不相关的黑客事件，一堆……还记得 PlayStation 商店被黑，我们所有的信用卡信息都被泄露了吗？哦是的，但我认为这是不同的，这是破解实际的硬件。所以下一个是，我们知道它在那里，但它正在到来。所以这是我们谈论比特币。是的，我们在 2011 年 3 月谈论了比特币。是的，如果我们当时买了 100 美元的比特币，即使是今天，我想我们仍然会有数百万美元。所以比特币，Jason，你觉得比特币怎么样？
You think it's got a future? No, it's not going anywhere. It's not going anywhere it's not going anywhere I think what we should do is we should take the Bitcoin that we mined on our university computer and software take all those coins and sell them for six dollars a piece that's what we should do yeah what would you say what would you say if I would sell you some Bitcoins for like 10 cents yeah that'd be awesome yeah i'll take it how many would you like to buy uh so we talked about the bitcoin java client and what bitcoin was oh man then we talked
你觉得它有未来吗？不，它哪儿也不会去。它哪儿也不会去，它哪儿也不会去。我想我们应该做的是，我们应该把我们在大学电脑和软件上挖到的比特币，把那些币全部以 6 美元一个的价格卖掉。我们应该这样做。是的，如果你以 10 美分一个的价格卖给我一些比特币，你会怎么说？是的，那太棒了。是的，我会买的。你想买多少？呃，所以我们谈论了比特币 Java 客户端以及什么是比特币。哦天哪，然后我们谈论了
about uh comics c-o-m-i-x which i believe is a uh like an e-comic yeah that's right man wow that's why that was before that was before like comiXology and Amazon having like Kindle comics which is how I view myself today that was before you had all that subscription stuff so that's changed a lot yeah yeah I mean a whole and Marvel movies and yeah yeah the way comics work today and and how they're in mainstream culture is super different so this is this is a good one episode two uh um well there was a there was a ted talk for a guy who tells some pretty funny jokes using math but i actually really like this uh we had a video making fun of of hillary clinton not knowing what firefox was and uh so spoiler alert patrick and jason know who wins every election we could just call it right here oh that was uh in march 25th 2011 um yeah that's hilarious so on the news you know ios uh four that was on the news and uh um and uh yeah apple 2 emulator it's pretty cool yeah this is a wild throwback so
关于 Comics，C-O-M-I-X，我相信这是一个电子漫画。是的，没错。哇，这就是为什么……那是 comiXology 和亚马逊拥有 Kindle 漫画之前，那是我今天看待自己的方式。那是在你拥有所有那些订阅服务之前，所以那改变了很多。是的，我的意思是，整个漫威电影，是的，今天漫画的运作方式以及它们在主流文化中的地位非常不同。所以这是一个很好的例子。第二期……嗯，有一个 TED 演讲，一个人用数学讲了一些非常有趣的笑话，但我其实真的很喜欢这个。我们有一个视频嘲笑希拉里·克林顿不知道什么是 Firefox。所以剧透预警，Patrick 和 Jason 知道谁赢得了每一场选举，我们现在就可以宣布了。哦，那是 2011 年 3 月 25 日。是的，那太搞笑了。在新闻里，你知道，iOS 4，那是当时的新闻，还有……苹果 II 模拟器，很酷。是的，这是一个疯狂的回忆。所以
so is there anything uh anything interesting in some of the uh some of the episode three stuff yeah so here so i'm looking at episode three now and i mean so i see that the tool of the day for me was key pass so apparently i used to actually give useful tools of the day not games and i still use key pass uh it's i'll use this for a second as a little a little different but someone was asking me someone recently had a death in their family um and they were sort of saying you know how do you make sure that like other people would be able to access it and i don't have a great story for like if both my wife and i passed away but i was like you know basically for my wife and i you know we keep all of our passwords
那么在第三期的一些内容里有什么有趣的东西吗？是的，所以我现在在看第三期。我的意思是，我看到我当天的工具是 KeePass。所以显然我过去确实提供有用的工具，而不是游戏。而且我仍然在使用 KeePass。我借此机会说一下，虽然有点不同，但有人最近问我，有人家里有人去世了，他们说，你知道，你如何确保其他人能够访问它？对于如果我和我妻子都去世了的情况，我没有一个好的故事，但我当时说，你知道，基本上对于我和我妻子，你知道，我们保存了所有的密码
in a key pass save that we have sort of backed up and synced really well so that if something happened to me, she could get into all my accounts. And then we have a very long, unique password with strong instructions to never use that password anywhere else
在一个 KeePass 存档里，我们备份并同步得很好，这样如果我出了什么事，她就能进入我所有的账户。然后我们有一个非常长、唯一的密码，并有严格的指示，永远不要在其他任何地方使用该密码
for that key pass save. And I felt pretty good about that. And so that's sort of my strategy. But apparently I must have started, I've been using KeePass for nine years, so since April of 2011. And you use it too? Yeah, yeah, I've been using it since we found it
用于那个 KeePass 存档。我觉得这很不错。所以这就是我的策略。但显然我一定是从那时开始的，我已经使用 KeePass 九年了，所以是从 2011 年 4 月开始的。你也用它吗？是的，是的，自从我们发现它以来我就一直在用
and that show, which is totally bonkers. So that's a product that's really solid. So here's another, here's a good news article. Google hires the inventor of java to work on android oh i remember that yeah um this is james gosling that was talked about yeah that's right you know so i have a funny story actually so i i um i ended up meeting james gosling and uh um he gave a presentation and he came to the presentation with a shirt that said, well, it said F word PowerPoint. So the shirt just said that.
在那期节目里，这简直太疯狂了。所以这是一个非常可靠的产品。这是另一条好新闻。谷歌聘请了 Java 之父来开发 Android。哦，我记得那个。是的，这是 James Gosling，当时谈论的就是这个。是的，没错。你知道，我其实有一个有趣的故事。我最终见到了 James Gosling，他做了一个演讲，他穿着一件衬衫，上面写着……嗯，写着“F word PowerPoint”。所以衬衫上就写着那个。
And like, I think he must have made it himself because it just was like an aerial, like whatever the default font is that comes with MS Paint. You know, he just got that and then went to a t-shirt transfer company or something it's just an f powerpoint and then and then he he just gave a whole presentation um with with no screen at all like he just talked and i thought that was hilarious and then i think about six months after he joined Google, he quit. And he went to work on some robotics thing. Yeah, I don't know how long he was there for.
而且，我想他一定是自己做的，因为它看起来就像 Arial 字体，就像 MS Paint 自带的默认字体。你知道，他只是弄了那个，然后去了 T 恤转印公司什么的。就是“F PowerPoint”，然后他做了一个完整的演讲，根本没有屏幕，他只是在讲。我觉得那太搞笑了。然后我想在他加入谷歌大约六个月后，他就辞职了。他去搞什么机器人项目了。是的，我不知道他在那儿待了多久。
But yeah, he's not at Google anymore, I don't think. I think he's moved on. Yeah. All right. In episode eight. What about episode? Oh, I was going to jump to eight. We talked about developer versus programmer versus computer scientist, which I think that's actually still today a pretty relevant thing.
但是的，我不认为他在谷歌了。我想他已经离开了。好的。在第八期。那第……哦，我本来想跳到第八期。我们谈论了开发者与程序员与计算机科学家的区别，我认为这在今天仍然是一个非常相关的话题。
It's actually surprising that almost a decade later, we still just call everyone software engineer. Although now there's machine learning engineer. So at least there's like, I guess type of distinction yeah so i see in here the in episode oh where was it uh in episode five i was gonna say that uh that was the first time apparently we thought it was newsworthy that ios would allow you to do updates over the air you wouldn't have to plug into your computer to update your phone that's amazing oh my gosh that's that's pretty good oh man things were so different i don't even know that i had a smartphone at that time oh okay in in episode 10
令人惊讶的是，近十年后，我们仍然称每个人为软件工程师。虽然现在有了机器学习工程师。所以至少有某种区分。是的，所以我在这里看到，在第五期……我在哪里看到的……在第五期，我想说的是，那是我们第一次认为 iOS 允许你进行无线更新是值得报道的新闻。你不需要插上电脑来更新你的手机。这太神奇了。哦天哪，那太好了。哦天哪，事情真是太不同了。我甚至不知道我当时是否有智能手机。哦好的，在第 10 期
um minecraft was still owned by notch and uh and and uh someone um someone was claiming Bethesda, actually. Wow, I didn't even, I totally forgot about this. So Bethesda, I guess, had a game and Notch was making another game and they had the same name. And Bethesda said they were going to sue. And Notch said he'll play their best player in Quake 3. And if Notch wins, he gets the name. And if the Bethesda employee 3 and if notch wins he gets the name and if the bethesda
Minecraft 当时还是 Notch 拥有的，而且有人……有人声称是 Bethesda。哇，我甚至完全忘了这个。所以 Bethesda，我想，有一个游戏，Notch 正在制作另一个游戏，它们名字一样。Bethesda 说他们要起诉。Notch 说他会和他们最好的玩家在《雷神之锤 3》中对决。如果 Notch 赢了，他就能保留这个名字。如果 Bethesda 的员工赢了，Bethesda 就能得到这个名字。那个游戏从来没出来过，对吧？不，是的，他确实做了另一个游戏叫《Fun with Blocks》，我愚蠢地买了它，以为 Notch 做的任何游戏都会很棒。说实话，它其实很糟糕。但好吧，我不敢相信这是那么久以前的事了。进入 2012 年，第 15 期，我们报道了 Facebook 要 IPO。哦天哪，哦不，我想他们确实 IPO 了，但他们 IPO 之后股价下跌了。我们当时说这有点幸灾乐祸，但人们当时在报道他们，指责他们在 2012 年 IPO 后股价下跌了 11%。我敢肯定我现在会以 IPO 价格买入。是的，我想 IPO 价格是
employee wins and bethesda gets the name that game never came out though right no yeah yeah he did make another game called fun with blocks which um uh which i bought foolishly thinking that you know any game notch makes would be amazing and it was it was actually terrible to be honest but uh well i can't believe this is this long ago so moving into 2012 episode 15 we covered that uh facebook was gonna ipo oh my gosh oh no i guess that they did ipo but they ipo'd and they went down and we were saying how it was like i guess a little bit of schadenfreude probably at the time but people were covering that they were blaming that they went down 11 right after they ipo'd in in 2012 i i'm pretty sure i would take it at the ipo price now yeah yeah i think the ipo price was uh
大约 15 美元，然后跌到了 12 美元左右。是的，我绝对会买。哦天哪，这真是疯狂的视角。所以是的，这并不觉得是很久以前的事。是的，在第 12 期，我们介绍了树莓派（Raspberry Pi）。哦，我不认为它在那之前很久就出来了。我的意思是树莓派……是的，树莓派，甚至人们现在基本上……不，我想那不是真的。Arduino 和树莓派，我想它们现在已经是主食了，很难想象没有它们会是什么样子。是的，在第 14 期，我们宣布了 Pebble，他们倒闭了。他们被收购了，对吧？Intel 买下了他们还是不？嗯，算是吧，我的意思是他们基本上倒闭了。我的意思是他们被收购了，但如果我没记错的话，价格并不好。
was like 15 and it went to 12 or something yeah i would definitely take that oh man yeah it's crazy perspective man so yeah uh yeah it's that but it doesn't feel that long ago yeah in episode 12 we introduced the raspberry pie oh and i don't think it had come out much before that i mean raspberry pie is like yeah raspberry party and even people largely have been well no i guess that's not true arduino and raspberry pi i guess they're just such staples now like it's it's kind of hard to imagine what it would be like without those yep uh in episode 14 we announced the pebble and they're out of business they got acquired right then intel buy them or no well kind of i mean they basically went out of business i mean they were acquired but it was not a good price if i remember
是的，好的。所以第 17 期，或者在 2012 年 8 月，我们谈论了 Ouya 的疯狂销售。哦天哪，我记得那个。我记得看着那个，心想那太棒了。那正是我想要的控制台。它能玩所有这些很棒的 Android 游戏。然后，是的，大约六个月后，它就没了，对吧？这太疯狂了。是的，我的意思是，他们筹集了 800 万……我现在点击 Kickstarter 页面，他们筹集了 860 万美元。我想今天大概没人玩 Ouya 了，对吧？也许有人玩。不可能，我的意思是，我会说得更肯定一点，我认为在他们拿到 Ouya 一年后，就没人玩了。哦天哪，在第 16 期，我们宣布了第一款微软
correctly yeah okay so episode 17 or in august of 2012 and we talked about the uh gangbuster selling of the ooya oh my gosh i remember that i remember looking at that and being like that is amazing it's exactly the console i want it plays all these awesome android games and then uh yeah like six months later it was gone right it's wild yeah i mean yeah i don't think uh they yeah they raised eight points i'm clicked on the kickstarter page now they raised 8.6 million dollars i don't think anyone probably plays uya today right maybe someone does there's no way i mean i would say even stronger than that i don't think anyone played uya a year after they got it oh man in episode 16 we announced the very first microsoft
Surface。哦哇，你还记得 Surface 过去像是一个桌面演示设备吗？哦是的，公司，然后他们只是觉得这个名字用在那上面太可惜了，所以他们决定把它用在平板电脑上。是的，我记得那个。我其实记得看过人们在那个巨大的水平屏幕上玩 D&D 的视频，看起来太棒了。等等，他们是在同一个房间吗？是的，是一群人在同一个房间里在 Surface 上玩，他们有自己打印的 3D 模型放在桌子上。看起来太棒了。哦，那很酷。是的，我们要开始了，Wii U 准备要出来了，伙计。那是 2012 年。你觉得它会成功吗？
surface oh wow do you remember surface used to be like a tabletop like presentation oh yeah companies and then they just like decided the name was too good to use on that and so they decided to use it for tablets yeah i remember that actually i remember watching a video of people playing dnd on that on that huge uh that huge screen that was horizontal like that it looked amazing wait were they in the same room though yeah it was a bunch of people in the same room playing on the surface and they had they had their own like 3d models that they had printed and put on top of the table it looked amazing oh that's cool yeah uh yeah here we go the w Wii U is getting ready to come out, man. It's 2012. Do you think that's going to be a success?
我不知道。这里有一些永远不会奏效的东西。2012 年，苹果收购了一家指纹扫描公司。什么？哦天哪，我不敢相信我们已经做了这么久了。他们甚至不再做指纹了。现在一切都是 Face ID 了。所以是的，这太疯狂了。所以我们在这里待得足够久，见证了他们收购一家公司，交付了一个产品，改变了一切，然后又弃用了它。是的，哇，历史的发展速度比你想象的要快得多。是的，这太疯狂了。哦天哪，好吧。
I don't know. Here's something that will never work. In 2012, Apple buys Fingerprint Scanning Company. What? Oh, man, I cannot believe we've been doing this this long. They don't even do fingerprints anymore. Everything's on Face ID now so yeah that's crazy so we're there long enough to they acquired a company delivered a product changed everything and then deprecated it yep uh yeah wow history moves a lot faster than you think yeah that's nuts oh man all right
我可以看这些，我立刻就知道是谁发现的。这个木制电脑套件绝对是 Patrick 在第 22 期发现的。那绝对是真的，那绝对是真的。是的，那是真的。新闻文章绝对有他们的指纹。所以是的，所以我记得谈论这些东西。我不敢相信……好吧，无论如何，我不敢相信这是七年前的事了。在 2013 年 1 月，我记得谈论 Bigelow 可充气空间站模块，他们要把它送到国际空间站。他们最终确实送了一些上去并进行了测试，但我的意思是，我不认为有什么结果。我再也没听说过它了。
i can look at these and i know immediately who found this like wooden computer kit this definitely came from patrick in episode 22 that is absolutely true that is absolutely true uh yeah that's true the the news articles definitely have a fingerprint on them yeah so so yeah so i and i remember talking about this stuff i can't believe well whatever anyways i can't believe this is seven years ago in january i and i remember talking about this stuff i can't believe well whatever anyways i can't believe this is seven years ago in january of 2013 i remember talking about the bigelow inflatable space station modules that they were going to send up to the iss they ended up sending some up and testing it but i mean i don't think anything's come of it i don't hear about it
是的，哇，第 32 期，如何创办一家机器学习初创公司，那是在 2014 年。是的，我周围的很多朋友在那个时候离开去创办机器学习公司。嗯，这取决于你的定义，这取决于你对失败的定义。我的意思是，如果公司被收购了，你得到的报酬基本上和你继续做普通工作赚的一样多，比如我知道的机器学习初创公司失败了。我认为归根结底，机器学习是一个让事情变得更好的好工具，而你改进的那件事应该是你的公司。你知道，就像你可以说谷歌因为机器学习或统计学（随便你怎么说）拥有更好的搜索引擎。但归根结底，他们不是一家统计学公司。他们建立了一个搜索引擎。所有那些出发说“我们要
anymore yeah wow episode 32 how to start a machine learning startup i was back in 2014 yeah so many of my friends uh around this time left to start machine learning companies and uh um well it depends on your it depends on your definition of failure i mean so so know, if the company gets acquired and you get paid basically what you would have made if you had just kept your regular job, like machine learning startup that i know failed which is i think at the end of the day machine learning is uh like a good tool to make something better and and that thing that you made better should be the company you know like like you could argue like google you know has a better search engine because of machine learning and or maybe statistics, whatever you want to say. And but at the end of the day, they weren't like a statistics company. They built a search engine. It's all the people who set out to say, like, you know, we're going
做深度学习并向人们收费”的人，并没有真正成功。是的，我再多说几个。所以 2013 年 9 月，第 29 期，我们有一篇文章说日产要在 2020 年实现自动驾驶。哦天哪，日产会有……伙计，他们还有八个月。他们还有八个月的时间。我仍然持保留意见。我想，你知道，我认为……这里的情况是，如果他们做到了，不是日产，他们就出局了。但总的来说，如果有人实现了高速公路自动驾驶，我想特斯拉已经有了，对吧？取决于你的定义。哦，真的吗？
to do deep learning and charge people for it. That didn't really work out. Yeah, I'll do a couple more. So in Septemberember of 2013 episode 29 we had an article that nissan was going to have self-driving by 2020 oh man nissan would have they got dude they got eight months they have eight months left still holding out i think uh you know i think well you know here's the thing if If they do, not Nissan, they're out. But in general, if anyone does self-driving highway, which I think Tesla already has, right? Depending on your definition. Oh, really?
是的，我的意思是，我认为如果你能从一个休息站开到另一个休息站而不碰方向盘，那就是我的定义。哦，所以你是想说我们应该为我们的第 200 期节目做预测笔记吗？这就是我听到的吗？是的，没错。哦天哪，你能想象 2022 年、2029 年会是什么样子吗？哇，那会很疯狂。哦，第 36 期，Twitch 被亚马逊收购，2014 年 9 月，那是六年前的事了。哇，这感觉更近一些。这是 Lytro 相机。那是另一件变得很大然后死掉的东西。哦是的，没错。
Yeah, I mean, I think if you could go rest stop to rest stop without touching the steering wheel, that's my definition. Oh, so you're trying to say that we should take show notes for predictions for our 200th episode is that what i hear you saying yeah right oh my gosh can you imagine what it's gonna look like 2022 2029 wow it'll be nuts oh episode 36 twitch bought by amazon september 2014 that was six years ago. Wow, this feels much more recent. Here's the Lytro camera. That's another thing that got pretty big and then died. Oh, yeah. Yep.
2014 年，第 33 期。哦天哪。看着这些语言，我必须说，我们涵盖的语言都相当稳健。是的。你知道，我看到的一件事是，我在机器学习和统计学方面有很多观点。其中一件事是，这对很多人来说是一个教训，就是有些事情现在我们有了潜意识的理解，而在 2014 年，绝对是在 2011 年，
2014, episode 33. Oh, man. Looking at these languages, I must say, the languages we covered are all pretty robust. Yeah. You know, one of the things that I'm seeing is I had a lot of views on machine learning and statistics stuff. And one of the things that's that that this is like a lesson for a lot of people is like there's things that now like are we have an unconscious understanding for that in 2014 and definitely in 2011.
我们真的很难理解，比如我有这个用于模拟的马尔可夫链，我记得当时这是一个非常难理解的东西。但现在我已经使用它们太多了，以至于就像第二天性一样。是的，没错。如果你很容易忘记我们当时知道得有多么少。就像你，你习惯了你现在知道的东西，你觉得你一直都知道它。是的，哦，有一个……第……哇，等一下，那是真的吗？所以 Windows 10 是在 2015 年出来的。Windows 10 已经五岁了，那不可能是真的。真的吗？我的意思是，我一直在偷偷回去编辑我们所有的节目笔记，让它们变得更搞笑。哦不，这是一篇谈论 Windows 10 的文章，
We had we it was really a struggle to understand like uh i have this markov chains for simulation and i remember at the time there's a really hard thing to understand um but now i've been using them so much that it's just like a second nature yeah that's right if it's easy to forget how little we knew like you yeah you get used to what you know now and you feel like you've always known it yeah oh there's a um episode wow wait a minute is that right so windows 10 came out in 2015 windows 10 is five years old that can't be right really i mean i've secretly been going back and editing all of our show notes to just be more hilarious oh no this is an article talking about windows 10
它将在未来发布，但仍然，它大约有四年了。所以是的，在第四期，我们谈论 Windows 10。所以谈论所有这些变化，但你知道，回顾这些，像很多这些工具，很多这些东西，我仍然在做和使用。就像你指出的，木制电脑，仍然有我感兴趣或有爱好的东西，它们已经持续了大约六、七、八、九年。我想我改变了很多，但实际上回顾过去，就像是，嗯，我不确定我们真的改变了那么多。就像你仍然在做机器学习，我仍然有嵌入式编程之类的东西。我们……事情可能会改变很多，但实际上它们保持不变。是的，就像你把变化正常化了，对吧？
which is going to come out in the future but still it's like it's going to be about four years old so yeah in episode four we're talking about windows 10 so talking about all this stuff that changes but you know looking back at this like a lot of these tools a lot of these things i still do and use and like like you point out like wooden computers there's still things i'm interested in or have hobbies for that that have persisted around like six seven eight nine years like i think i change a lot but actually looking back it's kind of like huh i'm not sure we really do change that much like you still do the you know machine learning and i still have like embedded programming stuff like we you might things might change lot, but actually they sort of stay the same. Yeah, it's like you sort of normalize the changes, right?
所以无论事情变化有多大，感觉就像是一个特定的速率。然后你回头看，你说，哇，实际上并不是那样。苹果开源了 Swift。他们真的做过吗？是的，我想那发生了。我想你可以直接……让我看看，Apple Swift GitHub。哦是的，就在那儿。是的，所以这在第 48 期非常相关。你想知道我的本期工具是什么吗，Jason？让我们听听。Wayward Souls。没门。
So no matter how much things are changing, it kind of feels like a certain rate. And then you look back and you say, wow, it's actually not that. Apple opens source Swift. Did they ever do that? Yeah, I think that happened i think you can just uh let me see apple swift github oh yeah there it is yeah so this is pretty pertinent in episode 48 do you want to know what my tool of the show was jason let's hear it wayward souls no way
所以无论事物如何变化，感觉上似乎都有一定的速度。然后当你回过头来看，你会说，哇，其实并不是那样。苹果开源了 Swift。他们真的做过吗？是的，我想那是真的，我想你可以直接……让我看看，苹果 Swift GitHub，哦，是的，就在那儿。所以这在第 48 集里非常贴切。你想知道我那期的节目工具是什么吗，Jason？说来听听。Wayward Souls。不会吧。
oh my gosh i actually uh um i i must have got that game because of you. But then I don't remember it and you say you loved it. Oh, man. Also, we talked a lot about source control and there's a lot of what I would call sort of roughly dead source control. I feel like it's all just Git and GitHub now. Like, I really don't hear anyone talking about anything else.
天哪，我一定是因为你才买了那个游戏。但我现在完全不记得了，而你说你很喜欢它。天哪。另外，我们聊了很多关于版本控制的话题，现在有很多我称之为“半死不活”的版本控制。我觉得现在全是 Git 和 GitHub 的天下。我真的没听过有人在谈论其他东西。
Yep. And that was just not clear in 2013 or 2014 based on what we were talking about yeah all right well i made it through episode 50 so in episode 46 um we talk about there's a there's a github gist like a little github um little snippet of code which are things that you can put in in a c++ file that will not make the program crash but will basically make the person's life really difficult so um i still talk about this today yeah because of this article define if while yeah so do things like put an if statement that every one in 100 times just evaluates true regardless. And it just makes it super hard to debug.
没错。在 2013 或 2014 年的时候，根据我们当时聊的内容，这一点还不明确。好吧，我回顾了第 50 期节目，在第 46 期里，我们谈到了 GitHub Gist，就是那种小型的代码片段。你可以把它们放进 C++ 文件里，虽然不会让程序崩溃，但基本上会让写代码的人非常痛苦。我至今还在谈论这个，因为那篇关于“定义 if 为 while”的文章。比如写一个 if 语句，每 100 次里有一次无论如何都会返回 true。这会让调试变得极其困难。
Yeah, that's right. Define if X to be if X and rand is less than 0.99. Could you imagine? Oh, my God. If you did that, it would be just total chaos for whoever came after you and it would be so hard to find all right well that's been pretty fun uh jason it's been nine years yeah i don't know what the future holds but uh hopefully less latent video conferencing and more awesome tech news yeah i mean well we need to finish with a prediction
没错，就是那样。把 if X 定义为 if X 且随机数小于 0.99。你能想象吗？天哪。如果你真这么做了，接手你代码的人一定会陷入彻底的混乱，而且很难查出来。好吧，这期节目很有趣，Jason，九年了。我不知道未来会怎样，但希望以后视频会议的延迟能少一点，科技新闻能多一点。我们需要以一个预测来结束。
uh oh no let me see i'm gonna you know i've been you know i've been making a prediction but i'll make i predict that uh within nine years that uh well this is i'm gonna it's gotta be bold so within nine years that i think that the way that high-speed internet works is going to be transformed by the satellite internet stuff that there's going to be so many extra satellites in orbit space is going to change i think the way that the world has changed just like how high-speed internet works by getting it via satellites from one of the many companies trying it uh the amount of rockets we're sending up um i'm pretty bullish on space i think people are going to be going into and out of space more than they do today and i know people have predicted
噢，不，让我看看。你知道我一直在做预测，但我会做一个大胆的预测：我认为在九年内，高速互联网的工作方式将被卫星互联网技术所改变。轨道上会有如此多的卫星，太空将发生变化。我认为这会像高速互联网通过卫星从众多尝试该技术的公司获取信号一样，改变世界。我们发射火箭的数量……我对太空非常看好，我认为人们进出太空的频率会比今天高得多。我知道人们已经预测了
this for decades and decades but i think the time is coming i think there's going to be more travel to and from space we've got spacex blue origin renewed interest in it the starlink stuff is happening i think in the next 10 years we're're gonna see a huge transformation in space. And I think I don't know what the impact will be. But I think it'll be big. I think there'll be a lot of jobs around that industry. And I think it's going to change a lot of how stuff works. Wow, that's bold. So you're thinking like no cable internet, like basically everything is wireless? Not everything. But I think i think like yeah you'll be able to just get high speed internet pretty like your laptop for instance like your laptop today basically gets wi-fi and not many people would pay to have their you know computer have a sim
几十年了，但我认为时机快到了。我认为往返太空的旅行会更多。我们有 SpaceX、蓝色起源，人们对太空的兴趣重燃，星链计划也在进行中。我认为在未来 10 年内，我们将看到太空领域的巨大变革。我不知道具体影响会是什么，但我认为会很大。我认为该行业会创造大量就业机会，并且会改变很多事物的运作方式。哇，这很大胆。所以你的意思是以后没有有线宽带了，基本上一切都是无线的？不是一切。但我认为，是的，你将能够非常轻松地获得高速互联网，比如你的笔记本电脑，就像现在的笔记本电脑基本上有 Wi-Fi 一样，没多少人会花钱给他们的电脑装一个 SIM
card in it i mean maybe people do i don't know and have hot spots i think that kind of thing will just become so cheap and ubiquitous that your laptop will, yeah, just use satellite for internet everywhere. Yeah, that makes sense. Makes sense. All right. My prediction is that I think university education will massively, massively change. I think that people won't get loans anymore. What will happen is there will be, I mean, there'll still be a loan, but I think basically there'll be a contract where people will invest in college students and then the college student will pay a certain portion of their salary back to give the return on investment instead of what we have now, where it's a loan system. So I think we'll, I think all of secondary, is that right, secondary?
卡，我是说也许有人会，我不知道，或者用热点。我认为那种东西会变得非常便宜且无处不在，以至于你的笔记本电脑到处都能用卫星上网。是的，这说得通。很有道理。好吧，我的预测是，我认为大学教育将发生翻天覆地的变化。我认为人们以后不会再申请贷款了。取而代之的将是一种合同，人们会投资大学生，然后大学生会从工资中拿出一部分来作为投资回报，而不是我们现在这种贷款制度。所以我认为，所有的中等教育——是叫中等教育吗？
Is that what you call college, secondary education? Yes. Yeah, right. I think all of secondary education will move from a loan system to an investment system where people literally invest in the future. And I think that that is going to radically change
你把大学称为中等教育吗？是的。没错。我认为所有的中等教育都将从贷款制度转向投资制度，人们真正地投资于未来。我认为这将彻底改变
so many other things. I think that that is going to like radically change um you know so many other things i think that that uh you know for one like the immediate change is that like like degrees will have to become commercially like like worthwhile right um you know and i think it's going to cause like more regulation and more like the people who give out these investments will will um you know they'll want to have some guarantees that they don't have now um but yeah i think secondary education will change enormously i think that you know the the the subjects that are not economically viable i think that they'll they'll find other ways to sort of teach people outside of like the university um like or or people will will pay out
很多其他事情。我认为这会彻底改变……你知道，很多其他事情。我认为，首先，一个直接的变化是学位必须在商业上变得有价值，对吧？而且我认为这会导致更多的监管，那些提供投资的人会想要一些现在没有的保证。但确实，我认为中等教育将发生巨大变化。我认为那些在经济上不可行的学科，人们会找到其他方式在大学之外教授，或者人们会自掏腰包
of pocket i guess um but i think that you know if you look at for example stem um i think that we'll have like all these this sort of investment system set up where people say you know instead of you spending you know 120 000 on credit um you know i'll pay for your college but then i want you know i don't know 130 000 or like i want you 10 of your salary for the next 15 years i don't know whatever however it works out um and i think it'll move to that yeah yeah that'll have a huge ramifications interesting i think that's called it's isa right Sharing Agreement. Having a personal ISA or whatever. Oh, I'd never heard of that. Yeah, I think that's the like finance industry term for it.
我想是这样。但如果你看看 STEM 专业，我认为我们会建立起这种投资体系，人们会说，与其让你背负 12 万美元的贷款，不如我为你支付大学学费，但我想要……我不知道，13 万美元，或者我想要你未来 15 年工资的 10%。我不知道具体怎么运作，但我认为会朝这个方向发展。是的，那会有巨大的影响。很有趣，我想那叫 ISA，即收入分成协议（Income Sharing Agreement）。拥有个人 ISA 之类的。噢，我从没听说过。是的，我想那是金融行业的术语。
Income Sharing Agreement. All right. Yeah. So I think college is going to go to at least not all majors. It's already more formal. It's happening. Your prediction is coming true. Done. Solved. But yeah, I think that will be the default way that folks do college, at least for some of these degrees. That's also bold. Also bold. I like it. All right. Thanks, everyone. Cool. All right. We'll catch you folks later. Next month, we're going to talk about working from home and all of that. Thank you so much for your support. Last month we did, you know, we were really in the midst of, you know, quarantine. Some people don't know this, but, you know, Patrick and I live in the counties that were the first to get quarantined. So we've been in quarantine for a long time. And so last month, you know, I just live streamed just myself writing some code.
收入分成协议。好吧。所以我觉得大学教育会朝这个方向发展，至少不是所有专业。它已经更正式了，正在发生。你的预测正在成真。搞定。解决了。但确实，我认为这会成为人们上大学的默认方式，至少对于其中一些学位来说是这样。这也是个大胆的预测。同样大胆。我喜欢。好了，谢谢大家。酷。好了，我们下次再聊。下个月，我们要谈谈居家办公以及相关的一切。非常感谢你们的支持。上个月，我们确实正处于隔离之中。有些人不知道，但 Patrick 和我住的县是第一批被隔离的。所以我们已经被隔离了很长时间。所以上个月，我只是直播了我自己写代码的过程。
And it was really cool to kind of talk to folks and the whole live stream thing. If you like the live stream and being able to talk back and forth during the stream, let us know. That's a format we don't typically do. But if people have interest in that, let us know. But either way, thanks a lot for your support
能和大家交流，还有整个直播的形式真的很酷。如果你喜欢直播以及在直播过程中能够进行双向交流，请告诉我们。这是我们通常不做的形式。但如果大家有兴趣，请告诉我们。无论如何，非常感谢你们的支持
and be safe out there. The intro music is Axo by Binar Pilot. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Sharealike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and sharealike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
注意安全。片头音乐是 Binar Pilot 的 Axo。Programming Throwdown 在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可协议下发布。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传播该作品，也可以进行重混或改编，但必须注明 Patrick 和我的署名，并以相同方式共享。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。